i'm starting to to take a little bit
more care of my help and health and i
start counting my actual calories and
let's say c is equal to the number
of calories i eat in a given day
number of calories in a day
and i want to lose some weight so in
particular i want to eat less than 1500
calories in a day so how can i express
that as an inequality
well i want the number of calories in a
day i want the number of calories in a
day to be less than
and remember the less than symbol i make
the smaller thing on i make this i make
it point to the smaller thing so i want
the calories to be less than
fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred so this is one way of
expressing i say look the number of
calories that i consume in a day need to
be less than fifteen hundred
now one thing to keep in mind when i
write that is obviously if i eat no
calories in a day or if i eat 100
calories or if i eat 1400 calories or if
i eat 1499 calories for c those are all
legitimate those are all less than 1
fifteen hundred but what about fifteen
hundred calories is it true
is it true that fifteen hundred
fifteen hundred is less than fifteen
hundred
no fifteen hundred is equal to fifteen
hundred so this is not a true statement
but what if i want to eat up to an
including 1500 calories i want to make
sure that i get every calorie in there
how can i express that how can i express
that i can eat less than or equal to
1500 calories so i can eat up to and
including 1500 calories right now this
is only up to but not including 1500.
how could i express that
well the way i would do that is to throw
this little line under the less than
sign
now this is not just less than this is
less than or equal to so this symbol
right over here
this is saying that c is
is
less than
less than or equal to
equal
to
15
1500 calories so now 1500 would be a
completely legitimate c a completely
legitimate number of calories to have in
a day
and if we wanted to visualize this on a
number line the way we would think about
it let's say that this right over here
is our number line i'm not going to
count all the way from zero to fifteen
hundred but let's imagine that this
right over here is zero
let's say this over here is fifteen
hundred
how would we display less than or equal
to fifteen hundred on a number line well
we would say look we could be 1500 so
we'll put a little a little solid circle
right over there and then we can be less
than it so then we would
then we would color in everything less
than
everything less than 1500 and say look
anything anything less than or equal to
1500 is legitimate now you might say hey
but what about the situation where it
wasn't less than or equal what about the
situation if it was just less than so
let me draw that too so going back to
what we were restarted if i were to say
c is less than 1500 the way we would
depict that on a number line
is
so
let's say this is zero
this is 1500 we want to make it very
clear that we're not including the value
1500 so we would put an open circle
around it notice if we're including 1500
we fill in the circle if we're not
including 1500 so we're only less than
we we make we were very explicit that we
we don't color in the circle but then we
show that look we can do everything
we can do
everything below that
now you're probably saying okay sal you
did less than you did less than or equal
what if you want to do the other way
around what if you wanted to do greater
than and greater than or equal well
let's think about that for a second
let's say that i'm also trying to
increase the amount of water i intake
and so let's define some variable let's
say w is equal to the number
of ounces
of water
water
i consume per day consume
per
day and i've read that i should have
i should have at least let me throw out
a number 64 ounces of water per day
so there's one way i could think about
where i always want to drink more than
64 ounces so that would be w is greater
than
64. so i always want w here is the thing
that i want to be bigger so the opening
is to the w w is greater than 64 ounces
so how would i depict that
well let me do my number line right over
here
let's say that this is 0
this is 64.
if i want to make strictly greater than
so in this situation it's not cool if i
just drink exactly 64. that 64 is not
greater than 64. i have to drink
64.01 ounces or 0.0001 ounces has to be
something that is greater than 64. so
i'm not going to include 64 but anything
greater than that
anything greater than that is completely
cool
now what if i i want to loosen things a
little bit like okay it's okay if i
drink exactly 64 ounces or more
well then
then i could write w is greater than or
equal to 64.
and the way that i would depict that on
the number line the way i would depict
that on the number line and obviously
i'm not showing all the other numbers in
between but let's say this is zero and
then we go all the way up to 64. well
now it's okay if i drink six exactly 64
ounces so i'm going to fill in the
circle now here i opened it because 64
was not a cool number now 64 is
completely okay i can drink exactly 64
ounces of water in the day or more and
then i just go up the number line
just like that